l'actualité estivale a relancé le débat
entourant les inconduites sexuelle et la
notion de consentement et à travers tout
ça s'impose une réflexion sur
l'éducation à la sexualité à l'école
réintégrer au programme scolaire
est-elle suffisante pour décourager
certains comportements nocifs
voici les heures qui sont consacrés par
année à l'éducation à la sexualité
depuis 2010 8 voici ce qui se passe en
ce moment dans notre système scolaire 5
heures au niveau primaire et 15h au
niveau secondaire par année mais au delà
des heures dédiées à cet enseignement il
ya la méthode contenu parlons-en avec
laurence desjardins sexologue et
coordinatrice de l'organisme on
s'explique ça qui offre des services
d'éducation sexuelle bonsoir madame
desjardins bonsoir
alors tout d'abord c'est important qu'on
qu'on sache bien ce qui se passe en ce
moment
qu'est ce qui est enseigné et pourquoi
vous jugez que c'est insuffisant
en fait le gouvernement le ministère de
l'éducation des études supérieures ont
fourni une enveloppe en septembre 2018
une enveloppe de contenu qui rendait
obligatoire donc ce qu'ont eue le sont
obligatoires par contre ne sont pas
nécessaires pour obtenir par exemple un
diplôme d'études secondaires donc très
rapidement avec l' enveloppe budget ans
et l'enveloppent au niveau du curriculum
toutes les autres maintien qui avait
chaque directeur doivent à présent gérer
cette enveloppe l'insérer dans des
programmes sont parfois déjà très serré
avec les professeurs qui sont parfois
surchargées donc on a une liste de
contenu qui va donc être donnée de façon
très hétérogène à travers les
différentes écoles de la province du
québec
une école que plus de subventions que
plus de ressources par exemple des
écoles privées vont peut-être avoir plus
de capacités au niveau personnel aussi
au niveau budgétaire pour offrir ces
contenus là de façon très approfondie de
façon professionnelle d'aller chercher
les sexologues à l'extérieur des
organismes versus une école qui a
peut-être moins de subventions moins de
ressources humaines moins de ressources
financières
voire peut-être avoir un peu plus de
difficultés à appliquer toutes ces
contenus donc on voit des jeunes
disparités au niveau des lacs lance au
niveau classe sociale on connaît aussi
la disparité au niveau des volontaires
dans les écoles ça va fonctionner de
façon volontaire donc en tant que
directeur est ce que j'ai des preuves
qui vont une volontaire a donné cette
matière laisse que je vais avoir des
preuves qui vont de 60 et confortables
sont l hôtelier suffisamment voilà
exactement sont-ils outillés donc les
professeurs vont recevoir une très
courte formation
donc c'est un petit briefing de quelques
heures pour leur dire voici votre liste
de contenu puis voilà donc une ville de
tournus ce n'est pas un programme
scolaire ans comme vous êtes un
professeur vous avez vraiment une liste
de choses à faire des objectifs pen est
une matière à donner pour préparer vos
élèves pour l'examen final obtenir un
diplôme est passé à l'année suivante en
éducation à la sexualité c'est une liste
de contenu donc le professeur se doit de
monter le contenu d'en faire un
programme de l'évaluer
alors ça commence avec beaucoup oui
c'est une c'est une charge quand même
qui est non négligeable mais parlons du
contenu justement qu'est-ce qui doit
être prioritaire dans le contexte actuel
cet été assez particulier qu'on traverse
tous ensemble qu'est ce qui est
prioritaire pour changer les mentalités
et surtout les comportements mais je
pense qu elle pas une priorité les
contenus sont assez bien développé
qu'elle soit vraiment bon alors dans le
contenu je vais me concentrer sur le
niveau secondaire tout simplement parce
que mon organisme se concentre là dessus
il ya eu çà va parler du consentement
oui tout à fait ça va parler de la
biologie ça va parler d'équité c'est ça
va parler de contraception mais ça m'a
aussi parlé de violences à caractère
sexuel des réseaux sociaux
l'impact des médias donc quand on parle
d'éducation à la sexualité
oui on va parler reproduction
contraception i t on le reçoit la
biologie il faut aller au delà de ça et
là on aborde aussi l'identité le jean
les comportements sexuels la
pornographie le consentement donc pas
une priorité mais faut pas oublier que
ces éléments le font aussi partie de ses
contenus le hac on assiste s'être autre
vague après la vague mitu
celle qui fait défrayer la manchette cet
été ça concerne davantage les plus
jeunes est ce que ça vous surprend
mais en fait oui je vais je vais être
honnête avec vous on disait que la
nouvelle génération la génération
cellule à la génération réseaux sociaux
facebook
on était cette génération là et à aller
coûte
on était bobo on était de vente où les
connaissances passé on était féministe
et puis l'on se rend compte que
finalement mais pas tant que ça puisque
tant de personnes sont pointés du doigt
ont commis des inconduites étant le
personnes ont été victimes de ces un
conduit tant de personnes n'ont pu
s'exprimer
donc et on voit vraiment qu'il ya une
problématique une problématique au
niveau de l'écho du consentement mais
aussi de l'exprimer ce consentement de
savon ses limites comme les limites de
l'autre donc on voit qu'il ya réellement
une problématique d'une ignorance dans
qu'est ce que c'est que la culture du
viol quelques c'est un rapprochement
saint positif et satisfaisant
consentants versus un rapprochement qui
est problématique
oui évidemment dans tout ça il ya pas
que le cadre scolaire et les parents en
quelques mots qu'est ce qu'on doit
savoir qu on est parents de jeunes
enfants mais je pense qu'il faut
simplement ouvrir le dialogue écouter
votre enfant quand votre enfant me pose
des questions répondez à la question
allez vous chercher de l'aide si vous
sentez désemparé ou que vous ignorez la
réponse il ya des ressources
communautaires qui vont parler
orientation sexuelle ou aux jeunes il ya
des sexologues qui sont présents en tant
que parent vous pouvez aller consulter
un sexologue en relation des lots niveau
éducation pour vous outiller donc y ont
des façons de d'ouvrir le dialogue et
d'accepter que votre enfant vous parle
de c02 ces questionnements et de ces
situations donc de poche juger et
d'écouté marchés importants laurence
dujardin merci beaucoup pour cet
entretien
merci beaucoup à vous au revoir en
soirée